[Music]
all right let's go out to Utah and talk
to Chrissy what's up
Chrissy Hi how are you Dr John paryan
what are you up to oh you know just
living Another Day in
Paradise very cool Lehi Utah that's
where Paradise
happens I I don't know I just moved here
over the summer so I'm still trying to
convince myself that's true oh you just
moved there this summer
yeah all right so you went through
summer in one of the most beautiful
places in the
world and you're about to go through
winter yeah I think it's a whopping 25
degrees outside so I went on a hunting
trip winter I went on a hunting trip out
in that area in February and of last
year of I guess earli this year and when
I called and said hey what how cold is
it going to
be guy goes
eight yeah this sounds pretty pretty
accurate yeah that was from a Texas boy
that was not cool all right so what's up
how can I help um so just to give a
little context uh the reason why I moved
to Utah actually is I got married in
July and me and my husband have Blended
families he has three boys or not three
boys three kids from his previous
marriage and I have one so now we have
three boys and one girl all together how
old um the oldest is 10 uh the next one
will be nine next month mine just turned
eight and our youngest is six oh good
good oh man amazing yall should start
saving for college that's gonna be a
rough few years okay so
10986 okay yep all right and I was just
wondering if you had any advice on how
to make blending a family a little bit
easier if that makes sense because
everyone talks about it but but I don't
know if anyone really knows what's
happening other than their outside
perspective yeah give me
um where do things stand right now y'all
are about six months in where do things
stand um it has gotten better the first
month was so hard yes and I just felt
like no matter what I did I was failing
these kids cuz uh me and my husband got
divorced over um similar situations and
so his ex-wife kind of dropped out of
the picture leaving Behind these three
beautiful kids and then my ex-husband
was kind of emotionally abusive not to
my son but just to me and so I just feel
like there's a ton of baggage going into
this relationship right correct I kind
of went in with the attitude of I'm
gonna fix this no all it did was or it
made me go crazy is the lesson I've
learned in that often when we we say the
words I'm going to fix this what we our
bodies do instinctively is we hold on
tighter oh yes and the opposite has to
be true and I'll walk you through why
and there's there's a lot of
Neuroscience here and a lot of nervous
system work like Dr pores I mean the lot
here I'm gonna paint it as simple as I
can make it okay okay and let's go ahead
and be honest and call out what you said
at the very beginning I haven't had a
blended family so I'm only speaking from
what the literature says what my
colleagues say and what my friends
who've tried
it have reported okay so I'm still
speaking as an outsider I think it's
important to call out there okay right
all right so you have a 10 a nine an
eight and a
six-year-old three boys and a girl
tossed in there right yes sir I said
that like sand lot and a girl right but
you've got three boys and a girl right
okay so I want you to keep a couple of
words in mind always always always this
will be for you and your husband okay
stability stability
stability routine
predictability things that they can
count on everything in their world has
fallen down but we often think of
falling down like a house
collapsing that's not what fell here the
house did fall but what crumbled is the
foundation the sidewalk that they walk
on everything they know and a lot of
times you and your husband are adults
yall can quickly get on a new footing
kids
cannot they absorb the footing from the
adults in their
life and so what we often do when when
people blend families is they spend a
lot of time on the house part who room
what's the decorations let's do fun
things and when what the kids need is
routine routine
predictability stability stability
stability that often means that Mom and
Dad have to go to counseling to regulate
their nervous system to learn how to
have
peace because the kids are absorbing
every every ounce of energy you're
putting out into the world okay so
everything I'm going to tell you going
forward is Guided by one word stability
how can me and my husband create
stability and predictability now he
might be an over the road trucker he may
travel a lot you may travel a lot you
may be on call cuz you're a nurse or
what that's all fine but there is a
routine to oh Mom just got called out so
here's what we do my kids and my wife I
travel a lot I'm always on the road and
my my wife and kid and Kids when dad's
gone here's what we eat here's how we do
bedtime it's it's it's their own little
world they've created it's amazing but
it's it's stability stability okay
that's the next one so here's the next
one I want you to consider
outbursts are simply unregulated bodies
trying to
adjust so what does that mean expect
anger expect the opposite which is
insane compliance Uber compliance which
is a trauma response too
sometimes explain you're not I mean
expect you're not my mom I don't want to
be here I hate you go back to wherever
it is you came from Mom I hate these
boys
why do we have a girl here all that is
is a 10 a nine an eight and a
six-year-old's bodies trying to make
sense of new
oxygen okay they're not
asses they're they're
kids right and what we do is we take the
words they say and the tone they use and
we we um transport it to adulthood and
if an adult talked to us that way they'd
be an
ass right these are
9-year-olds sixy olds okay their bodies
are simply trying to adjust that doesn't
mean we don't let them we we let them
run wild they're not feral but that
means we don't hold them to adult
standards yet because they're kids and
everything in their world has been blown
up
okay right so imagine um okay well I'll
just go on to the next one go very slow
this is the next one and by the way
we're going to clip this and uh if
possible clip it and we're going to send
it to you right away in its raw unedited
form that way you guys can have this
right away you we'll have to wait a
month for it to come out
okay so you didn't have to take notes
you can just we can just talk I want you
to go very slow a lot of like you're
like six months we should have this
thing together their whole that's
exactly how I feel their whole world
exploded right okay it
exploded your your new boys their mom
that I don't want
y'all
right which would crush anybody anybody
but that's not just a psychological
crushing that's not because when I say
psychological crushing you can't just go
yeah but I'm here that's not how that
works it destroyed their heart their
heart rhythms their nervous system
right your daughter grew up in a home
where Mom was not
safe she has absorbed how to navigate a
potentially like volcanic
man that's in her
body and so she's gonna have to learn
what a loving guy looks
like and feels like it's just gonna take
time okay okay so go slow here's the
next one never ever ever ever talk bad
about their
parents right for sure you know that but
I just want to reiterate they know that
half of them is you and half of them is
their dad or half of them is your new
husband half of them is the mom that
left right and so if it's like well your
mom did
this right right it's a sideways dis on
the kids it's not a sideways it's a it's
a hammer to their
head it's crushing it's a yes it's
crushing to a child that's why these
divorces that that are so contentious
where kids are used as as collateral is
I mean you're just you're ruining a
hundred years of lineage when you do
that if not more oh for sure it's just
abusive and that's kind of it is and
that's kind of what made me decide to
get married again is a couple years ago
I think my son was maybe six at the time
and I can't remember what even happened
but I got him back from his dad and um
his dad just said something kind of
snarky and rude and I was like H he's
such a butthead every time and we got
home and my son could tell just like you
said he just absorbed my
emotions right into his soul and was
like what's wrong mommy and I was like
oh I'm just annoyed with
Daddy and it was such an aha moment for
me that I was like my son doesn't
deserve to be my emotional support
animal I can't do that to him good for
you and husband doesn't get that anymore
he left he left he didn't get that
anymore he doesn't deserve that nope
your new husband does he can annoy the
crap out of you old husband he cashed
out right right if you go to if you take
all your money withdraw it from the bank
and you deposit in a new bank that old
bank doesn't get to tell you what to do
with your money anymore
period right okay all right so let's go
to the next one real quick um I want you
all to create a who we are
board W you go to Michaels or um uh a
Hobby Lobby something like that and get
a
canvas and I want yall to get music the
kids get to pick the music and if
they're already Savvy enough they get to
pick the
playlist and you and your husband get to
add a few songs that are just ridiculous
songs that y'all love like like whatever
ridicul poison or Dwight yok like
whatever songs youall grew up with just
ridiculous but we're going to create an
evening what um and I'm going to pretend
your last name is Smiths okay we're
gonna create a the Smith here's who we
are and we're gonna hang this somewhere
where everybody can see it and like the
delonis is we say yes to Adventures
Hospitality we treat each other with
dignity and respect and we're about to
redo it we did it when my daughter was
super super super young so she couldn't
participate we're about to do it again
but here's here's why that's so
important they now can have a touchstone
that they can see that they're a part of
something that is being built that is
new okay okay it's kind of like when
they're building a building they hang an
American flag out on on the big cranes
out there it's one of these things like
that's new and it's under this this
Banner also when kid when one of the
when the 10-year-old smarts off to you
you're not my mom I hate you you point
back and say Hey The
Smiths treat each other with dignity and
respect and you're allowed to be
frustrated I get that you you ha cannot
talk to the adults in this house like
that that's not who we
are and then when they like you when you
violate one of the who we are one of our
core values you are op in out you are
choosing to leave okay and so like last
night my daughter had a thing with she
was acting in a certain way and I said
hey come here real quick and I brought
her real close and we were eye Lev I was
sitting down and she walked ey Lev and I
whispered into her ear so as not to
embarrass her I said hey if you talk
like that again you are choosing to
leave the room and we don't like it when
you're not with us we want you here
but you can choose to leave which is
different than me kicking her out hey
you can't talk to us get out go to your
room because then I've just I've just
done what their mom did I've just done
what their dad did I've showed them
there is a line that you can't cross
that if you cross it I don't love you
anymore you're out of my presence and my
kids I want them to learn at a very
young age I will never send you out of
my presence you can opt
out if you come into my house
intoxicated acting what you're telling
me I don't want to be here cuz that's
not who we are but you're going to hold
the keys as to whether you're in
relationship with me because your old
man will love you to the moon back and
I'll come get you wherever you are see
the difference
there I do that's that's a big
difference a huge thought of it that way
okay so expect them to be bananas expect
them to be jerky and expect them to look
at you and say are you'all going to
leave
too and and in fact I'm going to push
you to see if you
will and they're just opting out all
right here's the last thing I'll I'll
I'll throw with you I'll throw a couple
at you real quick um conversation
journals with each kid that works with
some kids some some not so much but
everybody gets a spiral on their
bed and they get to write in it and
you'll respond every night and put it
back on their bed when they're at
school oh that's cute and it's just a
way to especially with younger kids and
actually it's worked with teenagers who
won't talk to their parents but they
might just write today didn't suck so
bad today I was happy that's it that may
be all I put and you can write a
paragraph today I thought of you and I
started laughing because that thing you
said last night you're
hilarious I saw how hard you were
working at this thing and it just brings
me so much joy whatever like we're going
to have just this dialogue back and
forth again one or two of your kids will
be like this is stupid I'm not writing
this a couple of your kids will it'll
latch on to them
if you can intentional time with each
kid that's tough especially when they're
this young it's just hard it might be
five minutes on the front porch and it
might be you with a 10-year-old like no
no no we have tea time at night
everybody away we get seven minutes of
tea
time and we're just going to have an
evening glass cup of tea or an evening
ice cream whatever the thing is but we
have seven minutes nine minutes it
didn't have to be an hour right um
here's the last two if possible give the
other parent op opportunity to win with
the opposite kids what could that look
like what if you took two of the boys or
the three boys out to buy a Christmas
present for their
mom that sounds insane and you'd have to
be a super emotionally regulated adult
to do
that to admit your husband had a family
before y'all got together to admit that
these kids are still connected to their
mom even though their mom is doesn't
treat them with love and respect now
that may not work in your house
but give them an opportunity what you're
showing them not by by by your words but
by your actions I'm not at war with you
with your parents with your mom I want
her to win I want y'all to love
her and they stop feeling the sense of
disloyalty to her every time they're
nice to
you ah I and your your kids stop feeling
disloyal to their dad every time they're
nice to your new husband it's like no no
no we're on the same team if your
husband took your two kids out one uh
six is is is old I don't know what your
son how old your son is but hey we're
going to buy a cool present for your
dad this I mean that's like money in the
bank wow see what I'm saying and listen
your husband I mean your ex may talk
crap about your new husband he sucks
next year he sucks next year he sucks
your kids over time you're playing a 10
or 15year game they will get it they'll
slowly go oh I'm being raised by a man
who's very secure treats people with
dignity my dad is immature and rude and
ugly I don't want to be there I don't
feel safe in there
anymore see what I'm
saying yeah it's not an instant
gratification kind of game we hey once
you have once you're divorced and you
have kids instant gratification is over
that leads me to my last Point don't
take anything anything anything
personally so hard I can't think of
something
harder don't take it personally don't
take it personally how his ex-wife talks
about you she's not well that's okay
don't take it personal how your
ex-husband is threatened by this new
amazing family y'all are building from
scratch he opted out don't take it
personally what a 10-year-old says to
you or when that 10-year-old becomes 14
I'm not going to take anything
personally I'm out I'm out I'm out the
only person who has permission to hurt
me personally is my husband my new
husband that's it and vice Versa kids
don't kids don't get that kind of vote
they can learn that hey you can't say
that it's disrespectful or you can say
I'm choosing to be hurt by what you said
but they're not going to hold the keys
to your kingdom like that because you're
the adult and you're the regulated one
so that's a lot I threw at you I hope
that helps um I wish you guys all the
best a in surviving a Utah winter and
building an amazing amazing new blended
family takes time go slow it's a lot
there
you guys can do it and thank you so much
for your heart
Chrissy